[Music]
my friend was like yo anyone watching
any good shows and my friend was like
super pumped is good like what's it
called
it's super pumped he's like i know
what's it called
[Laughter]
it's it's really good but it's just one
of those
super hollywood overwritten shows you
know what's cool about the show is that
like there's a lot of [ __ ] i didn't know
i knew they had a a lot of turmoil and
like kind of a bumpy come up and i knew
that he was a kind of a polarizing
figure there's a video that went viral
in 2017 or something of him like getting
in an altercation with one of his
drivers yeah you saw that yeah i've
never seen that yeah you piece of [ __ ]
yeah there's like a lot of [ __ ] that
happens in the show i'm like googling
the whole time i'm like did this really
happen it all did pretty [ __ ] wild
yeah you never know you might get the
ceo of the company screaming at you at
work yeah you just never know exactly
yeah it ain't right didn't hit him
though
if man can you imagine if you're that
uber driver and you just [ __ ] sucked
the [ __ ] out of him yeah would have
probably felt so good man i'm driving
for lyft now [ __ ] with these nuts in
your mouth
i think he eventually gets fired by his
board because of the toxic culture that
he perpetuated and so on and so forth
but he he got kicked out of the company
when it was worth like in the tens of
billions i think like 70 billion or 100
billion or something like something like
that and now he started cloud kitchens
which just raised money at a 14 billion
dollar valuation sweet it's nice did it
he's done it twice sweet pretty [ __ ]
crazy cloud kitchens cloud kitchens it's
like the company that like you know when
a new door dash restaurant pops up most
often than not it's like a kitchen in
some like work space that they just make
food all day from for different
restaurants they don't actually have
like a real retail location there's
something wrong with it i don't really
know what the issue is but like people
in the restaurant industry hate it yeah
but it's a [ __ ] giant company that to
me is not scary but that is like a weird
ass thing
like imagine you going doordash one day
and none of those are like actually real
restaurants that's [ __ ] strange most
of them aren't even now i don't use it
that much anymore so i'm not doordash
yeah
what do you do
cook
ugh um i cooked last night yeah yeah
what'd you make
rice and salmon oh and then i made
banana bread no bibimbap now that's only
when i cook
[Laughter]
yeah now i cook so that's crazy though
what a weird ass company
which cloud catches yeah what is that
pitch like so everyone likes restaurants
but you don't actually start one yeah so
we just get these people to work for
three dollars an hour i mean i'm sure
they get paid the same as a typical
kitchen staff yeah like four dollars an
hour the dark truth about ghost kitchens
um yeah let's just read this entire
article in 16 seconds i just read it if
you want to yeah what's the gist what's
the paraphrase basically uh brands are
using
ghost kitchens to expand their reach and
so people are getting like chick-fil-a
that's being made by just some kitchen
somewhere not at a chick-fil-a so what
and also places like chuck e cheese are
re-branding themselves to pass galleys
pizza and wings [ __ ] it that's the
thought so that people will eat their
pizza
you get the [ __ ] up pizza none of the
slices match yeah yeah yeah that's what
pascal's that whole thing there's a
place near me that has like four
restaurants coming from the exact same
ghost kitchen they all sell the same
food just with different names so so
it's shady that's basically what it is
it's like it's smoking mirrors you're
not getting what you actually want
that's so funny to get that like you
know on like uneven pizza and you're
like oh
okay and you walk down to the chuck e
cheese you're like who's pascali yeah
yeah
who's pastor i want to talk to pascali
no no no i want to speak to pascali i
know this is your [ __ ] pizza that's
pascali he's an animatronic
an animatronic italian chef
i'm pascali i don't get why reusing the
pizza is a bad thing like not reusing
pizza they make a pizza and they dish
some slices out and then when someone
orders a whole pizza they just put some
slices together so what it's not from
the same [ __ ] pizza
yeah
this is weird this is [ __ ] weird all
right pizza snob it's not even that like
you order a pizza you want this [ __ ] to
be fresh you want to feel like it's
yours you want to feel like
but if you order two slices from
different pizzas and they both show up
in the same box you'd be like yeah that
makes sense wait what are you saying
like if you go to a pizza by the slice
place you order two different slices of
two different flavors of pizza you're
fine with that
yeah but those come from two different
different pizzas but if you order a
whole pizza you just want to feel like
it's supposed to be your pizza man it's
just the experience did you even watch
chef
[Laughter]
that like
that pizza shows up in a box i would
feel like a cheese pizza and a pepperoni
pizza just [ __ ] into my box they just
like they just like let one off i like i
like the variety i would relate to that
piece get the [ __ ] out of here that
i wait an hour for that to show up
what's wrong with that that is [ __ ] up
who cares that is [ __ ] up you just you
don't know you just don't know it's
unsettling i know that's true if i did
order like a sandwich and both the
halves were like different different i'd
be like
yeah what'd they do with the other half
why why would they replace it you'd be
so pissed yeah i'll be pissed i'll just
become like
unsettled yeah
i'd be a little bit thrown off you get a
[ __ ] quesadilla and like the middle
piece is like way smaller yeah yeah i'm
trying to think what else you could
order that would be if it was weird if
it was uneven yeah that burrito is weird
yeah yeah it's just like one side is way
smaller
i don't like what do they do
did somebody eat half and then i think
that's the problem is you don't you're
sitting here and you're assuming good
faith but you don't know you don't know
what they're doing you know what the
[ __ ] you don't know if they took that
[ __ ] off a kid's birthday party and
they're like yeah just throw it in the i
thought it was like they make whole
pizzas and then you can either order a
slice or you order the whole thing and
so people that order slices they take
those empty slots and just replace it
with slices of other fresh pizzas i just
think it's the integrity piece there's
nothing to say that they wouldn't just
walk by here and be like yeah that's
good for later yeah i don't think
anything happened to that yeah they look
like they didn't touch it meanwhile they
like rewind in time and the kids like
licking the piece and then putting it
back in the thing he has the new covet
strain and he's like
just coughing all over that [ __ ] taking
it rubbing it face down on the seat